I got your wallets and graduation thank
you oh yeah this dezik there's a lot of
fun
yeah like that so I am an avid listener
and this is neon coast to coast get your
newsletter I'm 60 years old I would say
I'm in very good health except for one
pesky little problem I have Hashimoto's
I have been taking medications for about
ten years for that okay onion woody way
I played about 154 and I'm fine okay
five six okay well it's pretty good for
a girl okay any other problems skin
problems or history of asthma bronchitis
anything like that no okay good
no high blood pressure I just saw a
doctor of pharmacist Ben newsletter
where he talked about autoimmune
diseases and what she should take for
them and I would love to do that but
here's my problem
I get really sick when I take vitamins
I've tried everything I tried taking
with food some doctors have telling me
you've got to cheap of brands you need
to buy more expensive brands so my
problem is and my question is why is
that and what can I do about it serve
I'd love to be on the program okay well
you have to appreciate that a lot of
vitamins supplements actually have
gluten in them okay which is a filler
and they like to think it's helpful
because it has wheat and barley rye and
oak proteins in them and they can be a
negative for people they can cause
diarrhea they can cause constipation
they can cause people to have belly pain
even appendicitis Crohn's disease
colitis
diverticulitis leaky guts and all that
kind of stuff
all which makes your belly hurt and so I
didn't get rid of all the bad food whose
fried foods processed meats oils and
glutens and what would you what would
you have Kim take as a supplement
program to start out with charmaine
Shoei's under 54 pounds well I would
never take one or two healthy of stop
Xers he doesn't have any other issues as
a husband start packs with two of them
would do this job
that's a good place to start a healthy
start pack and and Hashimoto's is a
thyroid problem so what would you add to
the healthy start pack to make that as a
sigh roid heavy I would add some oceans
gold oceans don't see I get two bottles
of the oceans gold per month has take
three twice a day and if you you know
feel queasy or something like that try
cutting everything in half okay and
whatever your calculator doses cut
everything in half and take a half at
breakfast habits their time but chars
right to start out with one or is two
I'd go a to healthy start packs per
month to fold those four think twice a
day you had two bowels of the oceans
gold sinking through those twice a day
three of those tablets twice a day and
then make sure you're eating eggs you
know soft scrambled soft-boiled that
kind of stuff what would you what would
you what would you also take out of the
top besides we brought around
Oh char to help the thyroid heal itself
yes but I can't get to the Bulls you got
it right that's close enough you get an
A plus tear and cruciferous vegetables
Kim include cabbage broccoli cauliflower
Brussels sprouts kale and here is all
those things and because they do
interfere with thyroid function so you
got to get them out out of your diet and
many people say well I love all that
stuff well that's maybe why you're
having problems with your thyroid
because those types of vegetables if you
have one serving a week no problem so if
you're having a serving at breakfast
lunch and dinner every day you're going
to have a problem and then of course all
the different variations in between so
these are sort of things you need to be
aware of and that's why we're here to
educate people and make sure that
everybody can in fact be the best they
can be maximize your genetic potential
for health and longevity and form
intelligence speed and strength and
fending off disease